my big explosion happened in my  entrepreneurial Journey when I went from  having nine businesses at the same time  Dental agency marketing agency at a  chiropractor marketing agency I had gym  launch where we'd fly out and do gym  turnarounds and then I had five gyms of  my own at the same time and I was  somehow perplexed as why I wasn't making  any money everything was always on fire  all the time and I always just sold my  ass off enough to be able to pay all the  bills and have nothing left over and it  was only when Layla came in and she was  like you know I think maybe if we just  did one thing you could win because she  was like imagine if all you had to do is  make one of these businesses work how  easy would that be I was like oh my God  if I want to make one of them work would  be a joke and like I heard myself say  that and I was like you're an idiot and  so like the trait that I was missing at  that point was focus and or discipline I  couldn't say no